war with iran may be escalating or it
may not be we don't know but what I can
tell you is that last night as I started
an impromptu livestream as we learned
that Iran had attacked two US bases in
Iraq it was feeling a whole hell of a
lot like that evening in 2003 when
george w bush was president announcing
that we had started the war with iraq
iran has retaliated to donald trump's
assassination of the iranian codes
leader Kasim soleimani with missile
attacks on two US bases in Iraq this
includes the al-assad base and Erbil
which is another airbase this was very
much starting to feel like the beginning
of the Iran war although it's possible
that it won't happen and I'll explain
all of the possibilities momentarily it
has not yet escalated in that way but as
I watched the videos of the missiles
last night seeing the live news coverage
brought me back to the start of the Iraq
war right now we are not aware of any
casualties whether Donald Trump now does
or does not react is a materially
relevant foreign policy decision but
it's also related to some pretty clever
strategy by Iran thanks to Donald Trump
being so trigger Abul and so arrogant
and so egoistic and I'm going to explain
that because that really Trump's
personality could be the one factor that
determines whether this becomes the Iran
war or whether this stops here so let's
go through this step-by-step because
it's really important to understand the
comings and goings because this could be
an on-ramp to full-scale war or it could
be an off-ramp from further escalation
so Donald Trump ordered the
assassination of the Iranian codes
leader we've already covered this Kasim
Soleimani who was assassinated without
congressional authorization which Donald
from previously claimed presidents do
need to have Iran threatened to
retaliate and Donald Trump went to
Twitter and said if you do we will
escalate remember Donald Trump tweeting
quote Iran is talking very boldly about
targeting certain USA assets as revenge
for our ridding the world of their
terrorist leader who had just killed an
American
badly wounded many others not to mention
all of the people he had killed over his
lifetime including recently hundreds of
Iranian protesters he was already
attacking our embassy and preparing for
additional hits in other locations most
of this appears to be untrue by the way
Iran has been nothing but problems for
many years let the service a warning
that if Iran strikes any Americans or
American assets we have targeted 52
Iranian sites some at a very high level
and important to Iran and the Iranian
culture and those targets and Iran
itself will be hit very fast and very
hard the USA wants no more threats so
Donald Trump among threatening war
crimes they are pre committed to further
action if Iran retaliates so Iran did
retaliate
two strikes yesterday hitting two
different military bases in Iraq
although seemingly without any
casualties launching more than a dozen
missiles claiming that every missile hit
its target despite not killing anybody
now this was deliberate in the sense
that it was calculated this was a
sophisticated move by Iran if Donald
Trump does not want further escalation
Iran didn't kill anybody there are some
reports alleging that these attacks were
communicated ahead of time through a
proxy to the United States to ensure
that there would be no casualties at
these bases so that Iran can get a
retaliation on paper save face as the
case may be without actually killing
anybody and without forcing Donald Trump
to escalate further if he chooses not to
and in fact iran's Foreign Minister
Javad Zarif who also tweets foreign
policy said quote Iran took and
concluded proportionate measures in
self-defense under article 51 of UN
Charter targeting base from which
cowardly armed attack against our
citizens and senior officials were
launched we do not seek escalation or
war but we'll defend ourselves against
any aggression
this is actually an olive branch to
trump in the form of a possible off-ramp
if Trump actually does not want more
escalation this is a move by Iran that
allows Trump to stop here because Iran
didn't kill anybody this Iran this
Iranian attack does not force down
Trump's hand if Donald Trump is
determined to escalate he's going to do
it anyway now this is where it gets
bizarre yesterday in the midst of all
this Donald Trump tweeted during the
livestream that we were doing quote all
as well missiles launched from Iran at
two military bases located in Iraq
assessment of casualties and damage is
taking place now so far so good we have
the most powerful and well-equipped
military anywhere in the world by far I
will be making a statement tomorrow
morning this goes way too far this is
way too casual it's way too upbeat it's
almost like oh cool we're gonna have
bagels and smoked salmon as well because
this is all just so fun and we're all
having a great time I was actually
wondering whether this was even Donald
Trump or someone else may have taken his
phone and tweeted this all is well is
the phrase of someone who either is in
way over their head is completely
intimidated by the more sophisticated
strategic decisions being made by the
Iranians or is simply gas lighting
people my understanding of Donald
Trump's personality and ego make it very
difficult to imagine that he won't want
to retaliate but my sense is that there
are people around Donald Trump including
probably Secretary of Defense Mark Esper
who do not want an escalation and
recognize that it is not actually
necessary here now let's tail back to
the tactics and strategy piece of all of
this I do believe that if Donald Trump
does not do further military hostilities
that Iran likely will also not do
anymore
that seems reasonable the thing about
Iran is that much differently than Iraq
Iran's cyber warfare capabilities are
significant even if Iran's military does
nothing more in the military realm the
cyber realm becomes a real possibility
and one that Donald Trump's
administration has not taken seriously
throughout the presidency of Donald
Trump key takeaways number one this does
not have to be the start of World War
three as some are calling it or of the
Iran war as others are calling it but it
depends on Donald Trump and that's
horrifying
the that the decision about whether or
not the United States enters a major
military conflict
with a far better equipped opponent than
Iraq I'm not saying they're better
equipped than the US they are better
equipped than Iraq this particularly
that that decision rests on bogus
political grounds really primarily to
help Donald Trump be reelected and
distract from impeachment it is
horrifying that that's who and what this
depends on now I want to hear from
people in my audience people who watch
people who listen who want war with Iran
okay yesterday during our livestream we
had about 10,000 live viewers and save a
few obvious trolls and people who were
joking nobody says that this is a good
idea so if you support war with Iran not
because you think it'll help Trump get
reelected but if you think that there is
a worthwhile mission in going to war
with Iran tell me why you support it
what the targets would be what the goal
of the of this would be how would we
know if we've won and how long you
expect it to take okay I want to hear
from you if you were in that camp lastly
this is all about politics and it's all
about Donald Trump so let's talk about
that does a war with Iran actually help
Donald Trump we know that the
assassination of Kasim soleimani was a
political ploy to distract from being an
impeached president and to start
creating a pretext to justify his own
re-election there's a rule of thumb
there's a conventional wisdom that wars
are good for incumbent presidents it
allows them to say let's not change
horses midstream it frames them as more
presidential than their opponent because
not only are they running for reelection
they're also managing a war so
historically a military conflicts have
actually been pretty good for the
re-election of presidents but will it
work in this case it's not clear to me
that in this case it would help Trump
especially because there seems to be
very little support for attacking Iran
so I want to hear from you about that as
well would a war with Iran actually help
Donald Trump in terms of his re-election
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
follow me there follow the show on
twitter at david pakman show and we are
going to continue talking about this
later on today's program and throughout
the week as well I anticipate during
live calls on the Friday show Iran will
continue to be a topic of much
discussion quick break back after this
with much more